salut c'est Juliette vous vous souvenez
de Cannes je l'avais rencontré il y a 6
mois elle nous avait raconté de manière
hyper marquante l'inceste que son père
lui avait fait subir de son enfance à
son adolescence le côté
sexuel on va dire c'était le seul moyen
de le calmer et c'était mon seul moyen
de me dire ok il va pas gueuler la seule
échappatoire c'était d'accepter qui se
passe qui se passait à 17 ans elle avait
porté plainte et à 22 elle se préparait
pour le procès quelle est l'opposé à ses
parents j'étais partie à Nantes pour lui
passer une caméra pour qu'elle puisse
filmer les jours qui précédaient
l'audience
samedi jour 953
je vais aller acheter avec elle des
tenues
[Musique]
je me réveiller je sais pas qu'on se
brosser j'essaie de
[Applaudissements]
3 jours avant le procès elle apprend une
mauvaise nouvelle le procès est annulé
[Musique]
en fait le procès n'avait pas eu lieu
parce que l'avocat général était absent
et du coup il avait été reporté de 6
mois aujourd'hui il a eu lieu et je suis
retournée à Nantes pour connaître la
suite de son histoire sa version du
sujet action
depuis la dernière fois que je l'ai vu
beaucoup de choses se sont passés dans
sa vie elle a essayé de faire un max de
trucs pour oublier l'approche du procès
elle a déménagé elle est partie en
vacances avec son amoureux Axel
[Musique]
elle s'est mise à fond au sport elle
s'est lancée dans les nouveaux projets
de travail elle a pris du temps pour
elle et ses amis
mais c'était vraiment une couche contre
la montre j'ai pas j'ai pas arrêté pour
éviter de me laisser penser
jusqu'au jour
le procès commence à mercredi matin
calme est venu entouré de copains pour
affronter ses parents avec qui elle n'a
pas parlé depuis des années
là c'est tout le monde qui me soutenait
enfin pour te dire vraiment il y avait
du monde
il y avait vraiment du monde pour les
bancs étaient remplis
civil c'était
c'était exceptionnel honnêtement je
c'était dans le premier jour c'est son
père qui passe en premier à la barre il
raconte que lui aussi aurait été victime
d'attouchement sexuel par une
connaissance de la famille quand il
était enfant enfin j'ai pas vraiment
écouté mais en gros des sortes de la
touchement de la part de je sais plus
qui et la présente avait demandé mais
vous étiez consentants et il avait dit
puisque je n'ai pas dit non oui je pense
que je l'étais mais à chaque fois qu'il
dit j'ai quelque chose comme ça c'était
vraiment pour noyer le poisson on a
l'impression que c'était vraiment mode
myCam t'as pas dit non donc tu étais
consentante c'était vraiment il s'est
retourné un petit peu la chose à sa fin
c'était que des messages comme ça je le
vraiment je me sentais à chaque fois
visée et par exemple la présidente lui a
demandé elle lui a dit mais qu'est-ce
qu'on sentait là en voyant votre fille
et il a dit rien mais rien rien très
vite d'émotion
[Musique]
ensuite elle lui a demandé si vous
pouvez changer quelque chose qu'est-ce
que vous feriez moi je n'aurais pas de
fille puis j'adopterai un chien
et le pire c'est que c'est pas enfin
c'est pas ça qui m'a le plus blessé
honnêtement entre guillemets je
je m'y attendais mais ça faisait 8 ans
qu'on était en contact ensuite la mère
de Cam passe elle aussi à la barre pour
raconter son histoire et puis c'est au
tour de cam et donc au début je reste
assez comment dire je reste assez flou
on va dire je rentre pas dans les
détails et en fait la présidente me
posait question elle me dit très
concrètement qui va falloir rentrer dans
les détails parce que on est là pour ça
et j'ai dit ce que je pensais j'ai dit
ce que je ressentais j'ai dit ce que
j'avais vécu et mon père apparemment
était
sans émotion la tête baissée vers ses
pieds sans aucune émotion
quand je passe à la barbe à le fait que
en gros je lui disais concrètement tu
m'as fait ça je sais ce que tu m'as fait
et
aujourd'hui je veux que tu assumes et
que tu payes pour ce que tu m'as fait je
pense que pour lui ça a été entre
guillemets la goutte de trop le
lendemain tout le monde se retrouve au
tribunal tout le monde sauf le père de
calme ils attendent 10 minutes 15
minutes 20 minutes toujours rien
[Musique]
finalement la juge suspend l'audience en
attendant que les policiers aillent le
chercher comme se retrouve face à sa
mère dans le couloir du tribunal
et donc ma mère est à 100 mètres dans la
diagonale donc je la vois je regarde
Axel je regarde ma mère et là je vois
qu'il y a son téléphone qui sonne elle
décroche et elle a fait ce geste là je
relaxe
il dit rien je vois me pleurer et elle
me regarde elle me souvienne il est mort
[Musique]
le père de Cam s'est suicidé en
cependant devant la maison d'enfance ou
comme avec grandit et subit l'inseaste
et on sait bien que ma mère en fait on
s'est vu on a brisé l'injonction des
bloguement et justement c'est on est
tombé dans les bras de l'une de l'autre
ça faisait 8 ans que j'ai pas fait la
salade dans mes bras
le tribunal propose alors à cames de
reporter encore une fois le procès elle
refuse et demande au contraire qu'on
aille au beau comme prévu pour qu'elle
puisse enfin passer à autre chose calme
et officiellement reconnu comme victime
et son père qui a nié l'effet jusqu'au
bout et reconnu coupable je l'ai vu pour
la dernière fois au tribunal mercredi
soir
et je le reverrai plus jamais de ma vie
c'est un réel soulagement et en même
temps c'est une énorme tristesse parce
que
en fait son décès à apporter une dose
d'amour que j'avais pas prévu et je
pense que très peu de personnes ça
peuvent le comprendre mais
ça reste mon père quoi
et maintenant qu'il est parti je suis
juste en mode
j'aurais aimé pouvoir lui dire mes
derniers
enfin ce que je pensais en fait les
derniers dernières choses que j'avais vu
hier parce que j'avais encore des choses
à lui dire et malheureusement il m'a
enlevé ce droit là
la mère de CAM qui était jugée pour le
non dénonciation de mauvais traitement
est acquitté après 8 ans de séparation
elle se retrouve tu vois 10h45 elle
venait des signaux santé donc c'est
première photo
vient à la fin donc du procès ma mère
fait le tour et puis on se tombait les
bras dans l'une de l'autre et on pleure
et bah c'est très c'est très fort en
émotion c'est très chargé
après le procès comme invite sa mère à
dormir chez elle elle discute toute la
soirée de ce qu'elles ont vécu et enduré
pendant des années et se promettent de
se voir très bientôt quelques jours plus
tard je suis partie retrouver cam
il y a maman
[Musique]
ça va et toi
je t'envoie les codes par message
je t'envoie les codes
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose que j'aurais jamais
espéré
c'est irréaliste c'est réaliste
[Musique]
même si le procès n'a pas été comme on
l'attendait au final c'est vraiment la
meilleure fin que je pouvais espérer
sincèrement je j'étais reconnue enfin
j'étais reconnue victime il a été
reconnu coupable ma mère était libérée
on peut se retrouver
[Musique]
même si ça fait quelques jours qu'on
s'est retrouvés j'ai encore du mal à
à me mettre en tête que oui ça y est
j'ai retrouvé mon bébé
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
comme je vous le racontais dans le
premier épisode quand cam avait dénoncé
l'effet pour la première fois sa mère
avait pris parti pour le père contre sa
fille mais en fait comme cam elle était
sous emprise le procès m'a permis de
répondre tout à un tas de questions
c'est des choses que des questions qui
sont qui ont été licencieux pendant des
années pourquoi n'a rien dit pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'elle a vécu la comprendre
elle a rencontré mon père elle avait 16
ans il en avait 23
son compte que à cet âge-là tu n'es pas
construit que tu es manipulable comme
pas possible on sait très bien à quel
point une emprise peut être destructrice
ma mère était devenue
son son truc
elle a pas vu ma famille pendant
que elle avait vraiment personne quand
j'y personne c'est vraiment personne
je dirais que j'ai eu j'étais une femme
soumise et manipulée et j'aurais dû
ouvrir les yeux bien avant et partir
parce que je n'ai pas eu la force de
faire la seule force que j'ai eu c'était
l'année dernière donc
j'ai expliqué à ma puce aujourd'hui
c'est que durant toutes ces dernières
années et ben en fait pour éviter de
penser à
toute cette affaire
c'est peut-être l'âge de ma part mais je
me suis noyé dans l'alcool en fait et
cette dernière année qui vient de passer
devant l'abstinence ben en fait j'ai
ouvert les yeux et enfin la pluie
dernier quand
j'ai entendu ma fille à la barre
témoigner
le dernier pour cent je vais pas dire de
doute parce que voilà mais voilà et il
s'est levé et là
je me suis dit ma pauvre chérie je
suis encore aujourd'hui je lui dis que
je suis désolé
je vais pas dire dû avoir fait subir ça
mais parce que c'est pas moi qui lui
fait subir il n'était pas avoir pu
détecter ça je
je m'en vais encore aujourd'hui je pense
encore aujourd'hui
je lui ai demandé en sortant du tribunal
quand j'ai su que j'étais à quitter je
lui ai demandé est-ce que tu veux que
l'on passe un peu de temps ensemble et
tu veux que je rentre chez moi elle m'a
dit maman elle me fait du temps donc je
lui dis je comprends et en fait elle m'a
dit maman non tu restes là et après nous
avons été manger au restaurant ça me
fait un bowling et au bowling elle est
venue me voir et même je crois même si
c'était au restaurant qui m'a dit ça et
elle m'a dit maman fait la porte de la
maison tu es ouverte si tu dormais à la
maison ce soir tu peux dormir ce soir à
la maison et ben j'ai accepté je ne
pouvais qu'accepter et lendemain matin
je me rappelle quand elle s'est
réveillée elle a demandé à Axel a fait
dis-moi je rêve pas et Axel lui a dit
non non ta maman elle est bien dans le
salon elle a dormir à la maison
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression l'air d'avoir vécu
franchement l'équivalent de un an
d'émotion en une semaine tu vois
vraiment c'est
[Musique]
donc ouais mais on se retrouve on se
retrouve petit à petit
de la voir
voilà
une maman qui vit c'est plus beau des
cadeaux que je pouvais avoir tu vois
vraiment
chez toi et du coup que j'ai récupéré
c'est l'étage de resserre ici j'adore ça
magnifique ici la méta
V6
ans donc 5 6 ans donc 27
celle-là je la kiffe et même ma mère
elle m'a dit celle-là elle est trop
belle ah ouais non mais sincèrement vous
êtes magnifique tous les deux
peux pas oui tu peux la garder tu l'as
en numérisation mais tu peux
d'autres photos si tu veux
encore il y a toujours de la place
toujours pour le moment
[Musique]
depuis ce tournage cam et sa mère se
parle tous les jours il ne s'applique
plus elles sont déjà en train de
préparer ensemble une prochaine réunion
de famille enfin j'ai toute une famille
en fait qui m'attend donc
c'est dingue parce que j'ai une famille
de coeur que je me suis construite et je
m'en suis rendu compte au procès je suis
extrêmement soutenue et j'ai une chance
extraordinaire d'avoir toutes ces
personnes autour de moi mais ce qui me
manquait le plus au fond de moi vraiment
le plus c'était une famille de sang
[Musique]
le groupe avec ma famille en fait parce
que j'ai une famille
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a intéressé si
jamais vous avez d'autres idées de
sujets n'hésitez pas pour envoyer un
message sur Instagram et on se voit la
prochaine fois à toute
[Musique]